(police radio chatter, sirens)
- Someone we know
got murdered last night.
- You left the house in
the middle of the night?
Come on, what were you thinking?
- I'm a journalist!
- No, you're a fourth grader!
- A mark.
- Action.
- There was something I really loved
about the idea of doing a show
that everybody could
watch together.
- You can never just let
anything go, can you?
- I'm just saying that guy outside looked
like he wanted to M-U-R-D-E-R us.
- The show is inspired by the real-life
Hilde, who made national news
for breaking stories
in her hometown.
- It's this detective story,
where the detective duo
are an 8-year-old girl
and her father,
who is an
investigative journalist.
- Something derails him,
and we don't know what it is,
and the whole family ended up
having to leave New York
and go to this tiny town
in Washington State.
- Hilde starts investigating,
and unearths
a 31-year-old
cold case.
- No! No!
- Is that... Dad?
- The one thing I have
to bring to her is a strongness,
and she
won't back down.
The public has the right to know
that Penny Gillis' death
is now under investigation.
- How do I turn you off?
- There were places where I really
wanted be faithful to who Hilde was,
yet it's not based on
Hilde and her dad,
it's just inspired by these
beautiful things that they've done.
- I want to be able to inspire kids
that they don't have to
just be in boxes
that adults put them in
because of their age
or gender
or something
stupid like that.
- That was like... yes!
I know that you don't think that
you're a journalist anymore,
but I don't believe it.
- To see Hilde reporting on her own
after I stopped reporting,
to see her passion,
it made me love journalism again.
- 'Cause if the truth
doesn't matter,
nothing ever will.
- What else I love about this show
is that it's really fun.
- Putting together
the magical team that makes
the best version of something
is a gift.
Every day I'm on the set,
I can't believe it's real.
- BOTH: I declare a thumb war.
- I think this show
has the ability to inspire
a whole new generation of kids.
- It doesn't matter
what age you are,
what you look like,
you can do anything.
- If I had
nothing to do with this show,
I would want to see
what's going on next.
- You sound like a commercial.
- Well, it's true.
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
♪ I'll be your savior ♪
[shouts]
- Be smart.
- I'd rather be brave.
- Be both.